hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play to neveress Lake I've totally
forgotten where I am I've completely
forgotten what I was doing and why I was
doing it I don't know where okay oh yeah
the tunnel Jeremy that's right and damn
I lost my lantern okay all right I know
what I'm doing okay
[Applause]
hi someone being Myrtle eyes Din here
hello I don't have a lantern aha what
was that who's out here oh really
took all my oil how dare you
how dare you yes go in the door that
just mysteriously opened for me there
seems smart all right come on out I'd
show them mess with you
[Applause]
Oh
okay
alright I'm okay oh man oh god I just
wasn't expecting I've never seen one of
the things up close oh oh no that was so
bad oh I don't think I've ever screamed
that hard in my entire life Oh oh boy oh
man
now is something else Oh what the hell
whoa hey what up hey hey hey hey
Crouch holy [ __ ] ow ow ow ow jump
what
here let's go towards it I don't have a
menu I can access my journal I don't
even think I'm moving damn it
it wasn't even that scary
ah
yeah captured
I didn't even do anything oh oh good
good [ __ ] off I didn't even do anything
with the water pipe maybe I got I went
through it and I must have missed some
stuff musta missed a lot of stuff
oh man
okay all right let's get our buddy let's
get up buddy
I haven't even named you call you
Chester in honor of my good friend
Chester Worthing Hamm Worthington sorry
sorry Chester okay
I still can't open my menu so that's
problem I don't have a lantern it's just
a cell I tell you this Mahdi is crazy
awesome like of all the amnesia mods
this is by far the best I said that a
couple episodes ago but now I'm positive
of it it's crazy good I mean everything
about the pain ah doors blowing up and
in the wind
Yana Rama I take back everything I said
about this game being so creative
no this seriously the pacing is unreal
it's like I haven't even I'm like ten
episodes in and I've barely seen a
monster and what I have seen of the
monster has made me utterly terrified so
that's how it's supposed to be what was
that
on the journal later whoa hey buddy do
me hurt me pardon me buddy sorry buddy
hey push the pinata I wish you a boo you
out of the way fish you oh look at that
I don't think there's anything else okay
more stuff down here under the stairs
maybe or not hey look the same point
it's a trick trick its trick too dirty
oh no I'm back oh this is this is where
I started and now I have my stuff and
they took all my oil again I just filled
that up
it's not like I'm lacking for oil but
seriously whatever whatever this is
where I want to get the lantern
okay
design
here's something paratis magnum receptor
Coulomb okay oh good
hmm I can hear sounds but it's too dark
to see anything maybe they will lead me
the egg oh that was back when I heard
the sharpening of the flame so yeah that
didn't help me because I couldn't open
my book okay storage storage but ah that
was it X 14 was the lever was the pipe
so that the piston for pipe x1 4 of
course it's stuck X okay so what do I do
about that Darth thing full levers
willy-nilly until something happens
sounds about right
that's not right oh wait how does that
need to be
I need to walk out a monster storage ok
stores hub ah
it opens storage room ok
Oh close it close it close it close it
close it close it close it close [ __ ]
[ __ ] close that thing i totes called
that
okay we're okay okay just gotta wait
until it's gone and then we go on our
merry way okay there we go Oh God
[ __ ] these things oh that's what
those things are modeled after I see
okay then the box
[Music]
aha no no the oils to try what what the
oil is too dry cry cry into it add manly
tears
[Music]
I get the other door open there's a
puddle of water I've had some bad logic
in games but that maybe I'm wrong maybe
there is some core sort of dry oil
oil that can dry out and you could just
add some water to it moisten it right up
maybe that is
sometimes video game logic is worse than
like
Oh wet oil perfect all right
I'll add the wet oil to the mixture in
the next episode because anyway thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye